Photography is bigger
than just images.
It's bigger than a career.
It's a process of discovery,
both external and internal.
I want to invite you into
my world of photography.
Things aren't that
interesting for me
unless the stakes are very high.
And we're going to scramble
to the top, top, top.
With photography, you're
telling a narrative.
There's depth behind it--
one image to tell
this whole story.
Think about how they
look visually, what
your compositions look like.
The way I'm shooting this,
I'm underexposing quite a bit.
I know that I'm going to
pull up the shadows in post.
All of a sudden, it changes the
entire dynamic of the image.
It really begins before
you even pick up a camera.
When you're passionate
about something,
you know something deeply.
It takes obsessiveness.
It should be a calling.
Oh, god.
[LAUGHS]
The best types of shoots are the
ones where you're having fun.
[LAUGHS]
I think I'm going to
go a little lower.
I want him higher
in the horizon line.
And you build incredible
relationships.
Some images are
impossible unless you
have that relationship.
That's great, Conrad.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What I've realized
over the years
is there's always going
to be the next big thing.
Appreciate being in the
moment with what you're doing.
Photography is
such a cool vehicle
to give you access to the world.
Look at where the bar has been
set before and set it higher.
Ask yourself what you're
willing to do to get there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Jimmy Chin, and
this is my MasterClass.